Você vive cansado ou cansada, com a
mente a 1000 e quando vai ao médico,
seus exames de ferro dão normais ou até
baixos. E aí o que acontece? Eles te
mandam tomar ferro, mas você toma e se
sente pior, mais inflamada ou inflamado,
mais pesado ou pesada. Sabe o que que
isso acontece? Um estudo recente
publicado na Biometals mostrou que o
problema não é a falta de ferro, é a
falta de transporte.
Existe uma proteína no seu fígado que
funciona como um caminhão blindado. Sem
ela, o ferro enferruja seus tecidos e o
cobre solto frita seus neurônios,
causando aquela ansiedade que não te
deixa dormir. O nome dela é cerulmina e
eu aposto que seu médico nunca pediu
esse exame. Hoje eu vou te ensinar
protocolo de três passos para destravar
essa proteína e recuperar sua energia
mitocondrial. Então fica comigo.
Vamos entender a fisiologia sem
medicinês. Imaginem que o cobre, o ferro
são materiais radioativos. Eles são
essenciais para gerar energia, mas se
ficarem soltos no sangue, eles geram
explosões, o que chamamos de estresse
oxidativo. A cerulmina é equipe de
segurança. Ela segura 95% do cobre do
seu sangue e garante que ele chegue onde
precisa, sem causar danos. Mas a função
mais crítica dela, e é aqui que a
medicina ortodoxa comibola, é que ela
age como enzima ferroxidase. E que que
isso significa? Significa que ela
prepara o ferro para ser transportado.
Sem celuloplasmina suficiente, o ferro
fica preso dentro das células,
enferrujando seu fígado e seu cérebro,
enquanto seu sangue mostra anemia. Você
tem ferro, mas ele está trancado. É como
ter dinheiro no cofre e esquecer a
senha. E o resultado clínico disso, nós
vemos todo dia na clínica fadiga crônica
que não passe com café e dores no corpo,
que parece fibromialgia. Agora, preste
atenção, porque é aqui que a maioria de
vocês está errando feio na ânsia de
aumentar a imunidade, o que todo mundo
começou a tomar nos últimos anos. Sim,
zinco. Doses cavalares de zinco isolado.
O problema é que o zinco e o cobre
competem pela mesma porta de entrada no
intestino. Quando você inunda o seu
corpo de zinco, você derruba o cobre e
sem cobre biodisponível você não fabrica
celuloplasmina. E o resultado? O pouco
cobre que sobra fica solto e não ligado
à proteína. Esse cobre livre é tóxico,
ele excita o cérebro, aumenta a
adrenalina e causa aquela sensação de
estou exausto, mas não consigo desligar.
Outro erro clássico, fugir de alimentos
ricos em colesterol, vitamina A real,
como é o caso de ovos e fígado. A
pesquisa mostra que o retinol vitamina A
verdadeira, não o betacaroteno da
cenoura, é o sinal químico necessário
para o fígado produzir celuloplasmina.
Se você vive de clara de ovo e salada,
você não tem tijolas para construir essa
proteína. Então, qual que seria a
solução? Como é que nós resolvemos isso?
Não é tomando cobre sintético isolado,
que pode ser perigoso. O segredo é
estimular a produção de celuloplasmina
endógena. Anotem aí o trio de ouro que
usamos na visão funcional. Primeiro,
fonte real de retinol. Esqueça
multivitamínico de farmácia. Você
precisa de óleo de fígado de bacalhau de
alta qualidade ou consumir fígado bovino
orgânico cerca de 100 a 150 g por
semana. O retinol carrega o cobre para
dentro da ceroplasmina. Sem isso, nada
feito. Segundo magnésio, ele é o
maestro. A enzima que carrega a
ceroloplasmina é dependente de ATP e não
existe ATP sem magnésio. Eu gosto das
formas de malatoglicina, pelo menos 300
mg do elementar à noite. Terceiro,
fontes de cobra alimentar. Introduza pó
de pól de abelha ou clorofila líquida na
sua rotina matinal. São fontes seguras
que o corpo sabe usar. E o pulo do gato
pare temporariamente com zinco isolado,
se ele estiver acima de 30 mg e com a
vitamina C sintética, ácido ascóbico em
altas doses, pois eles podem atrapalhar
essa sinalização do cobre nesse momento
de reparo. O foco é comida de verdade
para sinalizar segurança ao fígado.
Quando você ajusta a ceroloplasmina, a
mágica acontece, o ferro sai dos tecidos
e vai para o sangue virar a hemoglobina,
a energia volta e a ansiedade baixa. Mas
atenção, existe um outro mineral que age
como freio de mão da sua tireoide, que
se estiver baixo impede tudo isso de
funcionar. Eu estou falando selênium,
mas a dose dele é traiçoeira. Se você
errar perde o cabelo. Então assista os
meus vídeos no meu canal no YouTube que
eu falo sobre o selênio. Saia do vídeo
agora se você gosta de ficar no
superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade conveniente. O YouTube e os
conselhos aqui me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos. Na
comunidade fechada não tem esse filtro.
Eu compartilho os exatos protocolos que
eu uso na minha clínica, casos de
reversão que parecem possíveis,
combinações of que funcionam e
fornecedores confiáveis, além de
interpretação avançada de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Nós temos
lives semanais respondendo perguntas PDF
com 47 protocolos exclusivos. Grupo no
WhatsApp, fantástico. Se você quer a
visão funcional real, sem simplificação
para as massas, clica aqui em seja
membro. E não é para curiosos, não é
para pessoas comuns, é para quem quer
resultados. Agora, se você quer ir ainda
mais fundo, existe o nível dois. A cada
duas semanas, fazemos lives de imersão
total com 2 horas de duração, desse
artigos científicos linha por linha e
debatendo controvérsias que ninguém ousa
tocar, revelando os bastidores das
pesquisas que a indústria não quer que
você entenda. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna parte
visível dessa comunidade elite que está
reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria dorme e assiste
passivamente, você estará ao meu lado
construindo um conhecimento de verdade,
tendo o seu reconhecimento público como
alguém que investe no que realmente
importa. Não é só sobre aprender, é
sobre pertencer ao círculo interno de
quem está mudando o jogo. Poucos têm
essa coragem. Você tem?